virus news tonight hair loss has now
become a common symptom of covid19
tonight mary jane belliesa shares how
one stylist is not only helping women
with their hair but providing them with
comfort during a difficult time
for ashley like building confidence goes
hand in hand with every style and every
consultation like is a hair stylist and
trichologist at cutting it short salon
with the background in hair loss and
scalp disorders she's helping a wide
range of clients like
eating for their blood type i'm a huge
proponent of that that actually will
lower the toxicity in the body they may
have a hormone hormonal imbalance they
may have
tractional alopecia most recently she's
assisting women who's experienced hair
loss due to covid when cosmetologist and
beauty instructor tracy young contracted
covid in december 2020 she had no idea
hair loss was a symptom but at that time
a lot of people weren't talking about
hair loss due to covet so really wasn't
a thing even my doctors did not know
what was going on with my body dr
alexandria lightning says this hair
condition called telogen effluvium is
triggered by high amounts of stress we
see this process happen after a woman
has given birth due to the changes of
hormones in the body we see it happen to
people who have major surgeries or other
stressful events that happen in their
life like says offering clients like
young alternatives during their hair
loss journey gives them hope i want
everyone to know
that you know it is a thing
and not to be afraid of it because the
hair will grow back it has to go through
the growth cycle it's a wonderful thing
to be able to show them what's possible
and that there are solutions there are
options you know you're not
just you know you don't need to hide in
the house in shame i have so many people
who only want to come on days that
there's no one else here it makes me
really feel like i have a purpose you
know i'm really like living in my
purpose so
i enjoy every minute of it every day is
different
mary jane valeeza live local now